Doors burst open, allowing the gurney to come
speeding through, followed by a gaggle of
concerned Foundation scientists and medical
personnel.
Everyone was abuzz, anxious at the troubling
development and fearful over the fate of the
patient lying on the examination bed.
It wasn’t exactly a rare occurrence for
someone working at an SCP Foundation facility
to need serious medical treatment, more often
because of a grievous injury or psychological
episode incurred whenever a dangerous anomaly
breached containment.
After all, working for the Foundation was
nothing if not hazardous to your health.
But personnel being injured?
That was so commonplace at the Foundation
that it was practically mundane, just another
ordinary part of the job.
It certainly never garnered this much attention,
with every researcher and medic on the site
all clamoring to try and assist or even just
get a look at who was on the gurney.
It wasn’t a member of personnel; it was
an anomaly.
SCP-049 was sick.
Nothing about the Plague Doctor’s behavior
had seemed out of the ordinary, he was normal,
at least, as much as a beak-masked, robed
creature could be.
Until, that is, one morning SCP-049 had just
collapsed in his holding cell.
The security camera watching him had recorded
the entire ordeal, with guards alerting the
research teams, and eventually calling paramedics
to come and escort the Plague Doctor to the
on-site infirmary.
SCP-049 was noticeably weaker, confused…
even afraid, some onlookers seemed to think.
“There’s no sign of physical injury,”
Doctor Cooper noted aloud, trying his best
to examine SCP-049 while the gurney was racing
down the hallways, and without touching the
Plague Doctor’s skin directly; one touch
and he’d die in an instant.
“All signs seem to point to something internal.”
Nobody had entered SCP-49’s cell in the
previous twenty four hours, the security footage
proved that the only people who had even come
close to the Plague Doctor were authorized
Foundation staff.
Doctor Cooper was right.
There was no indication that SCP-049 had suffered
any external damage.
If he’d been attacked, it would’ve been
caught by the security footage.
It had to be some kind of illness, the Plague
Doctor was slipping in and out of consciousness;
he could move and groan slightly, but only
had a few fleeting periods of lucidity.
But if he was ill, what with?
What was the cause?
Any symptoms, if there had been any leading
up to his collapse, must have been so subtle
that they had gone completely undetected by
everyone that had recently encountered SCP-049.
And was there a risk of cross-contamination?
Was everyone rushing alongside or following
the speeding gurney now infected also?
As they reached the infirmary, Foundation
medics were already waiting, having prepped
the area for SCP-049’s arrival.
Wearing gloves over their hands to avoid lethal
direct skin contact, the medical staff hoisted
SCP-049 onto a bed, just as Doctor Omel arrived,
pushing his way through the crowd of other
researchers and doctors who had piled into
the sick bay.
“Alright, the show’s over, back up and
give him some room to breathe!”
Omel shouted, before turning to get a closer
look at SCP-049.
“We’ve had a similar situation to this
before, if this goes the same way, then there’s
nothing to worry about.”
At that moment, SCP-049 briefly became lucid
once more.
“049, it’s Doctor Omel, can you hear me?”
“Y-yes, I can,” the Plague Doctor replied
weakly.
“Please, help me, Doctor.”
“Well, I’ll do my best,” Omel said,
trying to keep the beaked surgeon’s spirits
up.
“It’s a real good thing I was here that
time you laid an egg, at least we know what
to expect this time, right?”
“I’m not… not laying another egg,”
SCP-049 rasped through his beak, his pain
obvious in his tone.
“What?
Then what the heck’s going on?”
“It happened,” he answered, “P-pestilence.
It’s the Pestilence!”
before losing consciousness again.
The entire infirmary went deathly silent.
The Pestilence, the vaguely defined disease
that SCP-049 spent his life seeking out and
trying to cure.
Now it had infected him, and could potentially
claim his life, unless the Foundation could
help him.
There was one big problem: nobody had any
idea exactly what the Pestilence really was…
except SCP-049.
The next few hours were a non-stop circus.
An emergency quarantine order was issued,
as everyone that had accompanied the gurney
had to be screened and tested for any possible
signs of contagion.
If the Pestilence had actually managed to
infect SCP-049, there was a high chance it
could spread, especially with so many research
staff and medics present.
The infirmary was sealed off, any of the medics
who were ‘cleared’ was issued a hazmat
suit so they could continue to aid the sick
Plague Doctor.
Although confirming that staff were one hundred
percent clear of the Pestilence wasn’t exactly
straightforward, nobody knew what signs or
symptoms to even look for.
Normally, it was only SCP-049 and him alone
that could sense the presence of The Pestilence
in a human being… and his only ‘cure’
was turning them into a zombified instance
of SCP-049-2.
A momentary panic started to spread amongst
the Foundation personnel who had been near
SCP-049, stemming from one idea about what
the Pestilence really was: the Bubonic Plague.
It didn’t seem too far of a stretch given
SCP-049’s appearance, resembling the clothing
worn by medieval plague doctors when the Black
Death ravaged most of Europe during the 1300s.
Given that the bubonic plague was fatal, once
this paranoid rumor set in amongst the Foundation
staff, some began to break down, believing
they had contracted the deadly medieval infection.
However, after several hours of additional
screening and testing, nobody on site showed
even a hint of bubonic plague in their systems.
But, all the while, SCP-049 wasn’t getting
any better.
“We’re still in the dark here,” Doctor
Omel said, his frustration fogging up the
visor of his hazmat suit.
“If The Pestilence isn’t bubonic plague,
then what the hell is it?
And how do we cure it?”
“I’ve been going through the archives,
every interaction that SCP-049 has ever had
that we’ve got recorded, so far there’s
nothing conclusive,” Doctor Cooper replied,
swiping through various incident reports on
a tablet.
All the Foundation had ever truly known of
the Pestilence was based on SCP-049’s own
testimony.
They were aware it was an insidious infection,
capable of ultimately causing death in a subject
that had contracted it.
But anyone that SCP-049 had ever operated
on and turned into an SCP-049-2 zombie hadn’t
previously exhibited any anomalous or even
just unusual symptoms.
The Plague Doctor had only ever described
the disease in vague terms, and he alone had
been able to sense it.
“I went back over Doctor Hamm’s notes
after his interview with SCP-049,” Cooper
continued.
“Based on these, it looks like there are
a few working theories about what the Pestilence
really is, but…”
“But what?”
Omel replied.
“Come on, out with it!”
“Well, they’re pretty abstract, to say
the least,” the fellow Foundation researcher
admitted.
“The Entity is at the top of his list.”
“You’re kidding?”
Doctor Omel sighed.
The Entity was something the Foundation had
long been aware of, but had no way of confirming
if it even existed.
It had been learned about from SCP-5000, a
heavily damaged Absolute Exclusion Harness.
The suit’s data logs told of an alternate
timeline wherein the SCP Foundation turned
on humanity and began using various anomalies
to commit a worldwide apocalypse.
This had been done, according to the information
recovered from the harness, in order to combat
a being known only as The Entity, or “It”.
Apparently, this being had managed to latch
on to the human race’s collective subconscious,
and had been manipulating the entire planet
for some nefarious reason.
The Entity was what caused humans to feel
pain, and subsequently fed on that pain.
Although nobody was aware of its intentions,
the Foundation of this SCP-5000 timeline had
deemed it to be so diabolical that they had
resorted to wiping out humanity at all costs,
to prevent the Entity from ever succeeding.
“I think it’s a theory with legs,” one
of the medics chimed in.
“It can’t be, it’s so dumb,” Doctor
Omel replied dismissively, scratching his
head.
“Exactly, it’s so dumb, but so brilliant!”
the medic replied.
“No!
It’s just dumb!”
Omel shouted.
“Doctor Omel’s right, according to the
logs from SCP-5000, the Entity affects everyone,”
Doctor Cooper pointed out.
“But SCP-049 doesn’t attempt to operate
on everyone it meets.
If it was trying to combat the Entity, it
would have to ‘cure’ every human being
alive.”
“Where are we with treating SCP-049?”
Doctor Omel asked.
“The longer we spend yakking and doing nothing,
he could be getting even closer to death!”
“We’re seeing no chance,” the medic
answered solemnly.
The Foundation’s immediate course of action
was to administer SCP-049 with a single dose
of SCP-500, also known as the Panacea.
Coming in the form of a red pill, SCP-500
was known to cure a person of all diseases.
“But, as we all know, Panacea doesn’t
have one consistent rate of effectiveness,”
the medic explained.
“It can take longer to heal a subject depending
on the disease they’ve been infected with.”
“So, SCP-500 could be working?”
Doctor Omel asked.
“Like I said, we’ve not detected any change
in SCP-049’s condition,” the medic replied.
“It could be that the treatment isn’t
working at all because it can’t isolate
the Pestilence on the Plague Doctor’s system.
As far as SCP-500 might know, there’s nothing
there for it to actually heal.”
“Great, really that’s just wonderful;
we have a miracle cure that works on any illness,
and it’s just not doing what it’s meant
to,” Omel sighed.
“What about the next of kin?
Any luck there?
He’s notoriously good at evading capture,
believe me, I know.
But if we tell him what’s going on-”
“Not my department,” the medic shrugged.
“I’d say the fact nobody’s brought him
in yet means that our field agents still haven’t
found him, but your guess is as good as mine.”
“Oh, very insightful,” Doctor Omel said,
his frustration coming out as sarcasm.
“Just get the hell out of here and see what
you can do for SCP-049.
And send someone else to give us updates next
time!”
“Hold on, Omel,” Doctor Cooper interjected.
“Taking a look at Doctor Hamm’s notes,
and I’ve come up with another theory about
the Pestilence here.”
“Well, what is-”
“It’s death.”
The room fell quiet.
“Death?
As in the fundamental law of the universe?
The entire state of not being alive?”
Omel exploded with outraged disbelief.
“Listen, what if specifically dying of natural
causes could itself be the Pestilence.
Hamm was pretty old when he first interviewed
SCP-049, right?
And they had a number of sessions together
until one day, SCP-049 turns on him, senses
the Pestilence, and gives Doctor Hamm the
whole…
‘treatment’.”
“He zombified him, I know, you don’t need
to be coy, Cooper.”
“Right.
Well, during their very first interview at
Site-19, 049 said he could sense a lot of
death there, but not all that many traces
of the Pestilence,” the researcher explained.
“So, what if SCP-049 had started to realize
the odd little signs of Doctor Hamm aging
– greying hair, wrinkles, the usual suspects.
And instead of waiting for Hamm to die, he
cured him immediately.
Here, in an interview, 049 said this:
“Do you wait to remove rotten timbers until
the hall collapses on top of you?
No.
You find them, and you pull them out and replace
them with those untouched by rot!
And most of all, you do not simply mock the
structure because it now looks different to
you.
It is strong!
It is free of disease.”
“But not everyone he’s killed – or ‘cured’
– has been Hamm’s age.
There’s no way, we would’ve spotted that
pattern,” Omel reasoned.
“And if he was trying to stop people dying,
he wouldn’t start out his procedure with
that lethal touch of his.”
“Think about it, though, how does SCP-049
cure people?
You said it yourself, he zombifies them.
He reanimates them.
We’re all infected to him, everybody dies
after all.
So, he cures that with those horrific resurrections
and thus…”
“Cures death,” a flabbergasted Doctor
Omel finished the sentence.
“So, assuming you’re right and the Pestilence
really is just death itself…
SCP-049 is in the other room, dying from completely
natural causes?”
“And that might be the one thing even we
can’t fix,” Doctor Cooper nodded solemnly.
“Tell that to the O5 Council,” Omel muttered.
Suddenly, one of the medics – a different
one, as requested – came bursting into the
room.
“Sir, the next of kin!
One of the field agents has recovered SCP-049-J!”
The Plague Doctor was quickly rushed into
an operating theatre while doctors Omel and
Cooper watched from beyond a glass screen.
A shorter version of SCP-049 – his son,
SCP-049-J – was guided into the room.
The little plague doctor timidly approached
its father.
“Are you sure this will work?”
Docotr Cooper asked.
“I read the file on SCP-049-J, apparently,
despite all its claims of being a magical
wizard doctor, he’s never actually healed
anything.
Made a few conditions even worse, in fact.”
“I was around when Junior over there was
born,” Doctor Omel said.
“You know what SCP-049 said to me when his
egg hatched?”
“What?”
“He is the cure.
That’s how I know this is gonna work…”
Now go and check out “SCP-049 - BOILED,
SCRAMBLED AND FRIED - PLAGUE DOCTOR TALE”
and “A DAY IN THE LIFE OF SCP-049”!